The Joe Rogan experience, you have something.
As a breaking story and a former deputy assistant secretary of defense for
intelligence, Christopher Mellon, uh,
literally sent this to me about 15 minutes ago and he wanted me to read it
verbatim. So I was going to read this it's pretty startling stuff.
So I'll read it in the last 48 hours.
The public has learned of two stunning incidents captured on film by
us Navy carrier pilots. Earlier this year.
One of the cases features of photo of a bizarre flying
sphere and a black cube inside that is identical to dozens of other
reports, uh, by Navy pilots. Uh,
these strange objects have been shadowing East coast Naval ops since 2015,
they sometimes maneuver in formation and have occasionally been reported
achieving supersonic speeds.
The other incident produced a stunning detailed photograph of a
massive triangular shaped vehicle that emerged from the ocean and
flew vertically straight up and out of sight.
Just past a Navy F 18, operating off the U S uh,
aircraft carrier.
These iPhone photos taken by the pilots should be released to the public as
there are no sources and methods to protect and the national security benefits
of raising awareness regarding this issue,
vastly outweigh any conceivable benefit from concealing the
information.
It is hard to believe that in the face of such radical and incredible
technology within our vast defense department, the only,
we only have a so-called task force consisting of two individuals with no budget
who are still being off our stiff armed for access to relevant and timely
information by the air force and other security organizations
by comparison, 60 years ago,
in response to Sputnik America entered the space race,
which led to landing on the moon.
Our government needs to wake up and address the far greater technology gap that
these and many other incidents are revealing.
There is obviously a glaring strategic mismatch between the current task force
and the technology that has been identified. Why did he send you this?
Because he felt as a developing story and he wants people to be aware that
there's really compelling evidence right now,
photographically that needs to be released.
And so you told him you were coming on here and that's when he sent it to you.
Yes. And he said that that these people will need to feel some pressure. Um,
they need to,
they need to know that we are requesting not demanding,
but requesting further government transparency on this issue.
And he's very passionate about it. He knows of these photographs,
the governments, we w we got the story. I think it was yesterday.
And the government is refusing to release these photographs.
The pilots want these photographs released the people that are involved with the
incident, want the photographs released. And so we,
he wants the public to know that these photographs exist and that they should be
released.
And they're currently in the possession of.
Uh, he wouldn't reveal that he knows the person, but, uh,
but he said that the government is not wanting them released.
And he feels that they, that we have a right to these photograph.
And there's video that came with this story as well.
Well, remember, this comes from the very guy who, uh,
was strategic Christopher melon in getting those videotaped evidence from the
cockpits of those F 18 fighter jets off the East coast,
as well as off the West coast in 2004, 2015.
And ended up with that big story on the front page of the New York times in
2017.
Yeah. See that that's a new thing,
because if you went to like 24 or 2004,
when this all happened,
no one was really talking about UFO's in a serious manner.
Like it was still something that would be mocked and ridiculed,
but to have it on the front page of the New York times,
and to have this spokesperson for the Pentagon,
say that they've recovered off world vehicles,
not from this earth, not made on this earth. Like this is a, this is a change,
right? Uh, really, I mean,
even though it doesn't receive that much public attention,
cause it's all happening during a pandemic and everyone's just,
and also the news cycle today is so bizarre.
Something gets into the news cycle and then it's gone tomorrow because the new
scandal or people find out Elon's mean or whatever it is.
There's always something new that's coming out. And these, these things though,
they seem to,
it seems to be there's more of them and more of them coming out and with each
new story that comes out, people feel more emboldened to tell their story.
You know, I think personally everything changed in December of 20 2017.
When that page,
a front page of the New York times revealed that secret a tip program. And, um,
I know personally it could pick as I've gotten ridiculed for decades for the
work, I do a lot less so recently. Um,
people are certainly raising an eyebrow going, wow,
there's clearly something more to this than just, you know,
radar weather balloons and, and misidentified aircraft.
Jimmy pull up the video of that in that article. There's a,
there's an actual YouTube video.
There's two, one's from 94. One's from 26.
Let's go with the 2013 one. Um, but these, uh,
videos are very strange. You see these, this object what's interesting too,
is that okay? This is the one that I didn't see, but that this thing,
the way it moves and behave, the one that's from,
I guess it was from the 94 one, this is the 2013 one.
This is the one from Puerto Rico.
So it was just kind of cruising across the sky.
It's hard to track here in this black and white, there it is.
The, does it estimate how fast this thing's supposedly going?
It looked like they were near, uh,
some sort of like military base or something and on Agua DIA,
which is like the West coast.
So weird to see, like it's not clear what this thing is.
So one of the things that I think it's really good to establish.
Go, I'm sorry, but go, go further ahead.
In this video to see if maybe there's a better version of it or a better check.
The other one has the little clear video.
Yeah, there you go. That's much clearer. Like what is that? We'll live it,
that's not a bird like yes. Moving through the clouds.
One of the things I wanted to make a distinction of is the technology,
the observed technology that these guys are talking about.
So you've got objects with no wings,
no visible means of propulsion.
The ability to hover accelerate from a standstill to add a site in the blink of
an eye, right angle turns at high speed and fly rings around our fastest jets.
That is the technology that cannot be confused or explain the way is something
conventional. So anytime you see an object like we're looking at here,
if it performs or exhibits at that technology,
maybe it shoots off at a high rate of speed.
Does the right angle turn at high speeds? Um, no wings,
no tail, no propulsion, no Sonic boom.
Almost no sound.
That's. And they're trying to get a closeup on this thing.
So you get a better idea of what the shape is. It's very hard to tell,
but there's these objects also,
one of the weird things is it moves around the same way.
Commander Fravor described that thing,
moving around that was hovering over the ocean,
that it kind of darts around left and right, right.
And left almost like it's just not connected to
whatever our atmosphere is. It's like, it's moving into this weird,
zig-zag sort of a way.
This is an infrared image, right? It's not visible.
It's not a normal camera.
I don't know. I don't know what it is. Is that what it.
Kids with? Same type of camera that, uh,
has the ones from the Nimitz. So yo, you're looking at the heat signature,
you know, I'm not really looking at a visual picture, right.
So that's why it's not, not, you cannot get a clear definition of it.
Well, they need better cameras.
So if you go further along in the video, it does, uh,
they do get a better view of it. There there's. There you go. Like,
what the hell is that?
You know, that was one of the, uh, more startling, uh,
moments of producing the film of the phenomenon for me was when I met with
Senator Harry Reid, who spearheaded the ATP program,
the advanced aerospace threat identification program that wound up on the front
page of the New York times. Um, I wasn't quite sure when I met with him how,
where his comfort zone was.
And so I was really kind of cautious for the first half an hour of the
interview, but then I started,
started to relax and get more comfortable with each other.
And I decided to kind of push it a little bit. And I said, Hey, uh,
Senator I, uh,
met with Gordon Cooper who later became mercury astronauts who
told me on camera that there was a landing incident that took place at Edwards
air force base, or could 1957,
where they happen to have a camera crew out of near the dry Lake bed,
capturing the installation of a new landing facility for fad six fighter jets.
And it was broad daylight.
And all of a sudden this disc appears out of nowhere and the camera crew turn
their cameras on it.
And they filmed the landing of this flying saucer on the dry Lake bed at Edwards
air force base. And I'm telling the story to Senator Reed thinking,
you know, I don't know how he's going to react when I, but this is what I was,
I have them on camera. And uh, I said, he has the film footage developed.
It was good footage. He held it up, he looked at it, it was a disk, you know,
blah, blah, blah. And, uh, eventually he gets a courier jet from Washington,
DC that flies in pick up the footage, Senator Murray goes,
and it was never seen or heard from again. And I said, yeah, exactly.
And I said, did you guys uncover stuff like that? He goes, Oh yeah,
it's all there. It's we, we, we have it. It's all there.
And then he goes to change the topic and talk about something else. And I said,
well, hold on, Senator, uh,
are you saying that there's evidence that hasn't seen the light of day?
And he looked at me and he kind of pauses and he picks up his water bottle.
He drinks a sip of water. And that, that, that moment seemed like an hour,
but it was probably just a second or two. And he puts his water bowl down.
And he says, I'm saying that most of the evidence hasn't seen the light of day.
So that,
that for me was such a powerful moment because I'm going look at who this is
coming from. This is the former head of, you know, Senate, majority leader,
Harry Reid saying that the vast majority of evidence hasn't seen the light of
day. And if the president of the United States can't get access to it.
As I found out, when I interviewed all the people around president Clinton, uh,
who can, who has the authority to have this stuff released.
And that's something that I would love to know.
And I've been trying to find out.
So someone does someone in some position of government or some
intelligence agency, someone in the Pentagon,
someone or some group at the highest level of clearance
has access to this information and knows about it.
Absolutely. Senator Reed said they uncovered all this stuff during the program.
And he said the level of resistance that he got from the intelligence agencies
was insane. Like, I mean,
they did not want this project going forward at the Pentagon,
but they pushed and they pushed and they pushed and they got it through started
in 2007.
It went all the way up until it ended up on the front page of the New York times
in 2017. Of course, now we know that there's another project, but jock,
do you know who has the authority to release this stuff to the general public?
No, no, not, not.
In, in this particular case.
Nice catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.